pleased to say joined now by the
seven-time grammy award-winning musician
entrepreneur and activist will i am
hello thanks for joining us on the
programme
this morning i watched the video uh last
night on youtube
incredibly powerful imagery
tell me about the process that you went
through to decide
to rework it yeah i just looked at um
for one first thing for watching it um
but i uh i started thinking about
all the things that are at stake
and how backwards we have you know
traveled
um all the progress that was made all
the freedom fighters that fought for
the civil liberties that we have um
although we're not totally there yet but
it doesn't make any sense to go
backwards
it doesn't make sense that we have a
leader that steers up hate that
amplifies
you know division and tries his hardest
to confuse us
all with distractions it doesn't make
sense that we have a leader that doesn't
listen to science doesn't make sense
that we have a leader
that handled covet the way we've handled
to where people have lost so many
families lives and so many jobs
so many people facing eviction because
they can't pay their bills
and with all that i just asked like
where
why are we here in this place and when i
when i heard joe biden's speech at the
dnc i realized that that sentiment that
he
had in that speech marries where's the
love
and i quickly put it together and thank
you jennifer hudson for participating
with us and
letting your talents and your soul to
inspire people
to motivate them to go out and vote and
stand in long lines so we could
get on track get back on track
there were images of the ku klux klan
there were images of um children being
attacked by the police
was your motivation to shock or to
mobilize
to remind we with so many distractions
people forget so soon
and we've been so immune and numb to
just the inhumane things that you know
have been have gone on that we wanted
just to remind
people you know
the person in charge right now has done
a really good job to distract
and confuse um so we wanted to
remind and show just the horrendous
things that have happened
recently and how it echoes the stuff
that's happened in the past that we've
i thought we fought and moved past
this president has a strong base though
doesn't he people that
that feel that he best represents them
in america uh 21st century america
um i would say that
as i think there's more people
the popular the popular vote
and i think there's more people that
want to see america move forward um
in a more united way than there is
that are promoting the uh violence and
just the inhumane and
the way that um trump leads with with no
decency
i think there's there's more i have too
much faith in
um in america to believe that
what do you believe um will happen
if uh donald trump wins another four
years in office
i think we'll be set back america will
go from
you know a country that the world adores
to a country that people
um just can't figure out why america
aligns with a leader like trump i think
by 2020 to 2024
um we would have lost that position in
the world to lead
um and then we will be at no
position but to lead by force and that
should not be
you know the way to walk into this new
decade um we'll be in the middle of it
by 2024.
um new technologies would have emerged
rendering the jobs that we have now
obsolete and trump would have did
nothing to prepare people for that
um and if he got away with all the
things he got away
with for the next for the past four
years just imagine
how he would you know lead
with four years of uninterruptedness um
and i think that'll really set america
back
and it will hurt us i wonder how you
feel that the black lives matter
uh movement has changed america will i
am because
i had a contributor on the program
earlier on today we're talking about
the shops and storefronts that have been
boarded up in washington
ahead of the election result later on
tonight
many of them have black lives matter
painted on them
and my contributor was saying that was
because the uh
people that owned those stores were
fearful that if they didn't show
solidarity with
a black lives matter movement that that
their livelihoods would be destroyed
that's one person's opinion i think
black lives matter is
at its core is a peaceful um
demonstration to show that we at least
matter and and that if you as a black
man
the word black lives matter is like well
wait
why do we just matter why can't we have
importance
why can't we lead why can't we
why is it just matter so if you think of
someone that has the
audacity to argue that black lives don't
matter when we've been
you know misrepresented
not invested in you know we fill up the
prisons
the people that patrol our communities
are a lot of times
harming the communities and helping the
communities we're we're not being
educated as far as you know what's good
for our health so many of us are obese
with diabetes based on the food that's
adjacent to
the communities that we live in our kids
are not being invested in
um loans for for black families are
lower than
loans for you know white families um the
the amount of black people that we have
in leadership just in the tech sector is
like
invisible so anybody that's arguing that
black lives don't matter it is blind to
the realities that
what black lives have to go through not
just in america but
all over the world nigeria all
throughout africa
black people in australia black people
in in
india no matter where you go people with
dark skin complexion
doesn't really seem like they matter to
the systems that rule
so um i would have to uh
that one person's opinion unfortunately
uh
does not understand what it's like to be
black
in the world
what would you say um well i am too to
either side both sides there is some uh
concern that there may be civil unrest
depending on the results
uh that we see and whoever is put into
the white house by the american people
for the next four years
what would you say to those who would
incite
civil unrest
no matter which way it goes i hope that
people
don't take to violence for
those that are suffering and struggling
um unfortunately we're just gonna have
to struggle and
suffer more and if we've made it this
far
um we can make it another four years
but for the folks that are fearful um
please control that fear control that
anger
no matter which direction it goes
violence is not progress
that's just a bigger setback so
um and i know for a fact that black
lives matter is not
at its core violent you know imagine if
black lives matter was black supremacy
right imagine that but it's not what
it's saying it's saying we
matter to be you know given an
opportunity to be invested in
we matter to protect our youth and our
path
and our contribution to society we
matter
our the fight that we've had in the past
mattered from for fighting for equality
and we should still matter today that's
basically the sentiment and the
the mood and the vibe around the the
cause
and it's a just cause and those that uh
see everyone coming together supporting
it white black
latino everywhere around the world they
support that movement
that strikes fear to those that claim
they're supreme
because the world isn't coming together
for white supremacists
that idea that elite perspective
is uh you can't have that in the world
you can't you can't you can't have that
in the world
why should anybody be supreme over
someone else
absolutely um how much would you have
liked to have been in the united states
for the election
um i wish i could be with my family with
my mom
and sit down with her and my uh
my brothers my sisters watching
television
i remember what it was like in 2008
being
in chicago when barack obama was
elected president of the united states
um and this time i'll be in the uk
my second home watching it abroad
and seeing america from a distance
praying and sending energy that
we could get up from this you know ditch
um and move forward you know 2024
is a is a is an interesting
time for humanity there'll be so many
technologies that have uh that will
that we will adopt that will render so
many jobs obsolete it's not immigrants
it's not mexicans
um it's not you know it's not people
that are going to take these jobs away
it's the technology that we're training
right now
if you have an electric car uh with
self-driving mode you're training that
car to be a better driver
by 2024 so if you're a truck driver an
uber driver
you probably are not going to have that
job in 2024
definitely not in 2030 so if you're a
check
cash or if you're working out at a
retail store or a supermarket
or pharmacy you're probably not going to
have that job
because that little fast checkout
counter is training the machine to be
smarter and smarter to
understand our needs and if we're not
preparing
people right now rescaling and
upskilling it that's not the
conversation right now
then whoever is guiding us towards that
technological
autonomous tomorrow they need to go if
you have a distraction agent
they need to go if you have a chaos
agent they need to go
because we know look at what kovit has
showed us
in in 2018 what the hell was zoom we
didn't know what zoom was
in 2019 what was zoom we don't know what
zoom was we know what zoom is now
if you think of all the companies that
have boomed since kovitz they're all
tech companies our communities aren't
our kids aren't learning
um the way they should because our
leadership or not is not
leading properly to make sure that we
are protected and prepared for tomorrow
so for those that are okay you know a
part of the distraction
they need to go eject button hit it
out
just before i let you go prediction for
the night
prediction for the night is biden will
win
and we need some calming to do
we should all just take that moment with
a deep breath
and an exhale and a relief and then
really
dig deep into your soul um into your
mind and
and uh you know figure out what you do
to contribute
to a better tomorrow it's going to take
us all right remember in 2008 when we
had a mortgage crisis
and banks were bankrupt and obama and
biden were handed
crippled america uh biden was part of
that cleanup crew
and they stabilized he helped stabilize
america to hand over a stable america to
trump
for trump to just downhill spiral
um so when biden is elected
um in a you know less than
28 hours um
you got to think about what you're going
to do to contribute i know what i'm
going to do to contribute
i'm going to choose 10 states in america
to start robotics programs
uh that in communities that reflect the
community that i come from in east los
angeles
boyle heights and i want to get kids
prepared for this technological tomorrow
so i'm starting 10 robotics programs
in underserved communities to prepare
the youth
that's that's the least that i can do
and i'm going to do that
right so you need to look deep into your
heart and your soul and
figure out everyone that's watching what
you're going to do to contribute
when biden is elected